[Music]
you posted a high school picture of
yourself this gives us an idea of you in
high school
adorable and I love your coke okay
what's that quote that's Optimus Prime
my yearbook or Conan I'm a senior
that's my senior wait that's your senior
picture I'm 18 I'm 18 years old 18 there
oh my god I honestly thought you were
like and I love that there's an octopus
now all we need is a little Energon and
a lot of luck basically it's also a
shitty Optimus Prime for Optimus Prime
quotes than that the game won I can't
the adviser came up to me and he was
like you should change that this is how
people are gonna remember you and I was
like no I think I nailed it
[Applause]
Chris this is not public axe
sorry partner you're trash-talking I
think I made him their four-letter words
didn't yell at him kidding oh I can't
touch handy he's untouchable
yeah sorry he's all lawyered up I can
get virus I know what tell us what you
were like in high school I mean besides
not good Oh like that was me senior year
I didn't go through puberty until like
sophomore year of college and most of
high school I had a ball haircut so I
looked a lot like like Velma from
scooby-doo
and I was like really manic and just
like anything nerdy I did the most
extreme version of it like I was the
president of the junior statesman of
America I did all or even heard that
it's your statesman of America yeah it's
like an even sadder version of model
Congress it's like not good so if you
guys would get beat up by Marvel
Congress comes model Congress yeah I
played gong in the marching band that's
true
there's not good but the good thing now
it's like I have a TV show and we're in
our second season and I've started
getting Facebook messages from people I
went to high school with and this girl
Allison Gunn just asked me for tickets
she was like I'd love to come see your
your yes Allison Gunn was like hot when
she was like the hot unapproachable girl
shout out to Allison God and she was
really nice but I was not cool and it
was amazing to me I graduated high
school in 1998 and I'm like I'm 35 and
now girls I went to high school with are
starting to think I'm cool yeah great
yeah you get a TV show it really turns
around it's certain it certainly does
that's my favorite thing my favorite my
two favorite things are the girls that
used to ignore me that were incredibly
beautiful then later on saying you know
oh hey how are you we got a you know get
together and have another favorite thing
is the guys that would beat me up conve
now think honestly believe that I was
part of their pack and that I committed
crimes with that yeah they do
they believe that and I run to one
reunion and this guy who was like a
total criminal when I was this was like
remember that time you and I broke into
that liquor store and we we stole that
liquor then the cops came and we
scrambled out the back and I got copied
you got away when you drank all the beer
by yourself and you didn't bail me out
I'm like what are you talking about he
was like oh yeah mr. big time now
forgets his past yeah I wasn't knocking
over liquor stores they call me bro a
lot a lot of them send me Facebook
messages where they refer to me is bro
and they're like that is not the name
you called me in high school
you